[Music]
welcome to your new landfill a giant
ball of burning gas that we call the Sun
with surface temperatures of 5,500
degrees it could obliterate any type of
trash we throw at it from pesky plastics
to nuclear waste and with everything
we're launching into space these days
surely it wouldn't be too hard to send a
little trash to the Sun but how much
would it cost what dangers would be
involved and why would it be easier to
send a rocket right out of our solar
system than it would be to get anything
to the Sun this is what if and here's
what would happen if we sent our trash
into the Sun our our planet is filling
up with garbage yeah at the rate we're
going by 2050 we'll be dealing with 12
billion tons of plastic sitting in
landfills that's 35 thousand times the
weight of the Empire State Building sure
it would be nice to put it all in some
giant rockets and blast it off but there
would be some serious risks involved
like what would happen if there was an
accident while a rocket was in the
Earth's atmosphere and all our trash and
nuclear waste came raining back down on
us the Sun is about 150 million
kilometres away from Earth so getting
any Trash there would be extremely
expensive to put it in perspective the
Ariane 5 a modern European rocket has a
payload capacity of 7,000 kilograms and
costs approximately 200 million dollars
to launch into orbit so to get all the
planets garbage headed off towards the
Sun would take 168 million of the
Rockets just to remove our trash for one
year the price tank would be 33 trillion
dollars and that's just the cost of
getting the rockets into orbit around
the earth if we wanted to get them from
the Earth's orbit to the Sun it would
require ten times more fuel okay we get
it it would cost a lot of money but
that's just the beginning of our
problems
you see earth moves around the Sun at 30
km/s in a direction that's basically
always sideways relative to the Sun if
you were to launch a rocket from Earth
straight towards the Sun it wouldn't
lose that sideways speed and so it would
miss its target the only way we'd be
able to get that rocket right into the
Sun would be if we could cancel out all
that sideways motion by slowing down the
rocket by 30 kilometers per second
how'd Ricky would that be well put it
this way if we could speed up the rocket
by 12 kilometers a second it would have
enough momentum to get out of the solar
system so let's simplify that a bit to
crash into the Sun lose 30 km/s to get
out of our solar system gain 12
kilometers a second getting to the Sun
takes three times the effort for the
sake of efficiency and fuel costs it's
better to go to the outer solar system
where the rocket speed would be lower
then use a little booster juice to fire
the engines enough that the rocket and
its load of waste would fall into the
Sun even if we were able to figure all
this out and successfully deliver our
garbage rocket directly to the Sun it
probably wouldn't be worth all the risks
involved what risks you ask well for
starters let's say we've got our first
rocket all loaded up with a bunch of
nuclear waste and just as it's about to
take off it explodes on the launch pad
now we've got some fun nuclear fallout
to deal with
but maybe we're a little luckier and the
rocket launch itself is successful but
it explodes once it's in orbit the best
case scenario here is that we add a ton
of debris to the already growing problem
of space junk circling the earth the
worst case scenario is that our
exploding rocket packed with thousands
of tons of household trash and spent
nuclear fuel comes crashing back down on
us either way it's not good and this
whole operation really doesn't seem
worth it maybe instead of looking for
these outlandish solutions we should
just you know stop producing so much
waste before we could just say who cares
and see what happens if we start dumping
it volcanoes but that's a topic for
another what-if
[Music]